do we see enough great sci-fi on the
indie level or is sci-fi just one of
those things that only Hollywood can do
right well we kind of classifier selves
not quite as sci-fi but as lo-fi sci-fi
um and this is something I'm sort of
touched on and written about before
where you know when most who will take
about sci-fi they think of you at the
Hollywood stuff words like you know
things are blowing up and you know
things are flying there and like all
this sort of crazy crazy stuff is
happening and it's very much more of a
fantasy type 0 but like like me
personally I'm I'm a big sci-fi fan
being real sci-fi like the kind the kind
of science fiction that asked questions
about humanity and at its core that's
what it is it's it's trying to figure
out what human beings doing what human
beings do and what they're capable of
giving new circumstances I mean like if
we had the power to do something should
we do it could we do it and what happens
if we do and I think that's really what
sci-fi so that kind of sci-fi lends
itself really well to the indie world
because you are telling these characters
that have a sci-fi element but it's just
one of the story elements that your
embedded in its not about things blowing
up it's not about the big like cinema
feel to it it's it's a story at its core
about about human beings and it's almost
like it gives you some freedom to sort
of be allegorical about things and and
tell a story that that is unique or or
that it's different that would feel a
little bit too on the head if you didn't
have that sci-fi element you know but
you can ask really really deep questions
and you can provoke really deep thoughts
with whips I fight you know whether it's
in a short story or in a you know short
or whatever it is but I think that's
like what we what I think about anyway
when I think of science fiction it's
that the humanity 100
it and i think there i think there
huffing some of those lately in indy i
think it's definitely um much more
feasible now than it was in the past um
I think it's getting more popular I mean
I think we've seen it with Luke work
like the fact that that looper was even
made and that he made before that what
was the one with the UM no he didn't
like that sorry thanks remember that
whole clip um no um Duncan is it Duncan
Jones like him doesn't made moon and
then he made um the one with um source
code like those have been Hollywood side
lies that have you know a loud like
scifi and concepts playing with time to
become a little more popular but on the
India and there have been some awesome
ones like primer um when Brit Marling um
the two films that she's done another
earth and its on my boys have been
amazing I guess you'd call them low by
sci-fi but I think um where the
challenge lies is in what when you say
sci-fi people think you know big big set
pieces action um you know space and it's
it I think what's interesting to us or
is the syfy that the violet kind of
touched on it and we have seen some of
those films um be successful um but
that's not normally what that's not
where people's first op goes when they
hear sci-fi so it's about yeah you know
getting across the side by that that
you're trying to tell or show
you